this past Sunday I am cologne wrapped up
and I'm not being hyperbolic when I say
this might have been the greatest
Counter-Strike we've ever witnessed
concern
Ed so run him down simples posted twists
you've got no hope
no way FaZe defeated Navi to cement
themselves as the greatest team in the
world twist undoubtedly proved that he's
the greatest player in the history of n
a and despite the heartbreaking loss
simple is still the goat it was a great
weekend for CS go so let's unpack it all
foreign
[Music]
clone is one of if not the most
important event outside of a major hell
it can even feel bigger and more
exciting sometimes two of the components
that make cologne so special are the
fans in attendance and the venue itself
the Lang says Arena better known as the
cathedral is one of the most iconic
stadiums in Esports but IEM cologne
hasn't taken place since 2019 due to
covid so its return was highly
anticipated and as per usual the fans
did not disappoint
foreign
[Applause]
ing up we got some pretty great story
lines to start off vitality and G2
continued to struggle early on getting
knocked out in the group stages shortly
after g2's igl Alexi B announced that he
was allowed to explore other options and
recently there has also been Rumblings
that Vitality are looking to make
changes but nothing has been confirmed
but honestly that's no big surprise Nico
and zaiwu were two of the biggest
talents in the game and although it's
difficult to say what the solution is
it's clear something needs to be done
that being said if you're like me and
you don't give a about either of
those teams you got to watch them both
get knocked out by movie star Riders
during their unpredictable run to the
main stage this is it folks this is the
Spanish roster knocking down G2 into
that lower bracket a seven series
winning streak off the back of a win on
home soil at Valencia and now making a
run here at IEM cologne that's it folks
two and zero they know just moments away
moments away from locking in one of
their dreams it's a kill it's a doubled
some Pius brings them down on top of
that we also got to see some life out of
mouse for the first time since nbk was
benched if that wasn't enough any fans
finally got a glimpse of Hope in the
form of Team liquid's incredible lower
bracket run a crossfire established
they're backing themselves in this setup
it's just the AIM now
he's as well
Team Liquid making it to the playoffs
was even more meaningful since they were
actually the last team to win cologne in
the cathedral back in 2019 when they
completed their grand slam this was also
the debut of their stand in yakindar who
is a great talent but has been without a
team for quite some time now pressure
was at an all-time high for Team Liquid
but their experience wouldn't be enough
to extinguish the hot streak of movie
star Riders and their auberson Pius
crucial on the opening map but now one
versus three he'll step out and get that
one there should be a grenade coming and
there it is that puts the pressure on
but he's standing inside of it he's got
to go get the kid I don't think he has
time for this no he's gonna bail out oh
son Pius has done it
inside of the Flames picks off the kit
at distance unfortunately the Cinderella
run of the Spaniards would end up being
cut short by phase and on the other side
Navi would 2-0 astralis meaning the two
Titans would once again meet in the
grand finals and regardless of all the
storylines to emerge from cologne it
honestly felt like a navi phase Grand
finals was already in the cards despite
some thinking FaZe were in a bit of a
post major hangover they didn't drop a
single map and although electronic was
igling and some Die Young was still just
a stand-in now if you look stronger than
ever an sdy has to do it all in the 1v2
catches Farley could play with the doors
now play meth in the clutch looking for
his third
quick on the hunt is sdy he's not ready
an sdy holds his nub so honestly
speaking we felt pretty prepared for CS
Go's Newfound El Clasico well we weren't
prepared for was the most intense best
of five in the history of csgo it
started off with FaZe and Navi securing
wins on each of their map picks but
things seemed unfavorable for FaZe when
they found themselves down 15-4 on map 3
but with a standout performance from
twist FaZe clawed their way back to
overtime oh steak has another opening
not say why are the round rain again
aggressive and Shadow betrays them
they keep farming Twisted taking us to
overtime three kills 29 frides twists is
coming into his own a man possessed
there's no smoke brogie just has to
click oh look
[Applause]
at Grandy's proportions despite that
loss FaZe made a statement that they
would not give up and that momentum
carried them to a win on Mirage meaning
that the Grand Final would be settled on
nuke and good Lord it was the greatest
map I've seen in my goddamn life it was
back and forth Fierce as hell and
unpredictable just when you thought one
team had the upper hand a swift response
would reset the momentum elevated looks
away a moment with a trade broke
he needs this and he's all shut down
long range from Perfecto twist bounds
into the shot so we can
into the top hot player only sdy can
stop them and he does rain down Hell
Fire from the squeaky
just as phase we're about to throw the
final blow oh he sees you he sees you
around he wants you sdy
gets them to 10 and keeps them alive
everything would come to an incredible
final sequence Swiss would put the
tournament and his team's dreams on the
line with two of the ballsiest players
I've ever seen twists what is this this
is so smooth so aggressive unchecked
unscathed into the side face knocking
for six Navi evaporate do you consider
that he did it and he slaps him down
[Applause]
these backs
and the dying stages of Regulation as
they're gone 15. yes twists had rushed
many twice to secure tournament point
and with navi's economy and shambles the
turnmost phases twists put on the
performance of his career in those Final
maps and the win was owed to him but as
always the humble King couldn't take
credit for anything there's been a
constant debate over who the best player
in na is but I think without a Shadow of
Doubt twist is that guy and maybe he has
been for a long time hell if he manages
to get his second Grand Slam he might be
considered the greatest player of all
time but despite twist performance in
those Final maps and the heartbreaking
loss from Navi you can't deny that
simple is just a different breed there
was some conversation regarding twist
being snubbed of the MVP which I can get
but you can't deny that throughout the
whole tournament simple was playing some
of the best Counter-Strike he ever has
we have to come up with 18 seconds oh no
they're still in trouble the bomb is
down oh he tries to hit that one is not
that far off either 11 seconds now and
simple still feeling it he's still got
his finger on the trigger it's going to
be effective going down simple spinning
with one more kill on res tries to go
for the whole thing he's so crazy but
he's finally trapped in here doesn't hit
that shot either on the other side he
takes down Brolin simply no way well
there should be no way this is an
impossible round to win and it was from
the start he scoped up not realizing
hampers walking up closer oh no he Aces
his way back into the round after such
an incredible final fans creators and
Pros all expressed their amazement at
this insane weekend the consensus is
that cologne is just another reminder of
why we love this game and why CS go is
the greatest esport in the world we
might need a little break after this
weekend to recover but just look at the
rest of the year we got blast pro league
and the Rio major on the docket the
question is can any of these live up to
clone because I think the bar just got
permanently raised
led by the captain of our hearts
like says I want to hear you
never before seen your champions
[Applause]